I've never done something like this before. I've seen all kinds of populations of patients in emergency departments,
but to actually get out in the camps and see their way of life is really giving me some important insight.
This is a consortium of five universities and Emory is the head.
The reason I wanted to come here was because
I wanted to hone down my clinical skills, keep developing them,
but also to learn about the plights of the migrant farm workers in the United States.
If there's food on your table, thank a farm worker. They're here because we need them. It is a vital aspect of our economy.
They do our hardest tasks. They work for ten hours a day. Their access to health care is very limited.
Being a nurse, you have to be really flexible, and working with a population who possibly doesn't
speak the same language with you, you have to adapt your methods.
But that's kind of the fun part about it. You kind of have to how be creative and figure out how you're going to take care of the patients.
This is public health on the hoof. We are delivering preventive care and episodic care for the migrant farm workers and their children.
We have always worked with the federally-funded Farmworker Ellington Clinic.
The Emory program has helped us because we've built a lot of partnerships
and we've been able to contact experts
in different areas that have been able to help us out with with problems.
At Cox Elementary, the undergraduate nursing students, we rotate through three different stations.
Making sure they're healthy. We look at them head to toe.
Every child gets seen -- they get a full physical, they get dental, they get gross fine motor development.
Then the migrant workers come at night and it is episodic care.
The first night of night camp... it was an an experience. It was a lot more people than I expected. It was a bit hectic at first.
So at the night camps we help with intake of the men. We see what their chief complaints are, see what other
disciplines they want to see, if they want to see nurse practitioners. We also provide foot care for them.
Some of the common health problems that I've seen amongst the patients here...
The most prevalent I think is acute back pain.
Work-related muscle fatigue from repetitive motion, bending over and picking up and throwing melons into the back of trucks.
They get pesticide rashes.
They get pesticide burns on their feet from standing in the pesticide-laden  water.
It's actually really shocking,
because a lot of the men there are really young, but we'll find that
their blood pressure is super high, their blood glucose is really high,
haemoglobin could be low.
So even though they're young men that look very healthy, because of the conditions that they're living in, it really shows when we're testing them.
They have more of every kind of problem that you can imagine.
We do a lot of health education, health promotion, prevention.
So we try to advise them to drink water,
eat more leafy greens and vegetables.
But unfortunately, a lot of the men are limited in their access to the kind of food that they got to choose to eat.
So we try to work with them to see what's accessible to them.
It's helping to provide a public health education within the confines of someone's environment.
I really love the interdisciplinary aspect of this program. It's something that I hadn't really experienced before.
It's an interprofessional effort between nurse practitioners, pharmacists, physical therapists, dental hygienists.
And we all work together very well.
So we have a great communication and we all have the same common goal,  which is just to take care of the patients.
I love seeing how the students learn and grow and how they see health care in a different way.
I think that experience like this just keeps you humble.
I really think it's going to help me pause and look at the patient in a much more holistic sense.
I'll be a better provider when I come across different kinds of population.